la controvertida reforma pensional de
Francia está en movimiento Este martes
la primera ministra Elizabeth bone
anunció formalmente el proyecto que
apunta a Trazar la edad jubilatoria de
62 a 64 años para el 2030 una propuesta
que deberá ser sometida a discusión en
el parlamento
a generar comentarios debates y
oposiciones pero quiero decir que la
confrontación de ideas se puede hacer
sin desinformación sin despertar miedos
Entonces quiero ser Clara este proyecto
no se va a implementar de la noche a la
mañana
tras el anuncio los diputados franceses
se expresaron en contra y algunos
arremetieron contra la administración de
Manuel macron
lamentablemente no esperamos mucho
porque siempre hemos dicho que desde un
principio el gobierno tuvo falsas
consultas falsos intercambios y quiso
aplicar el plan que se impuso
Ahora solo republicanos los que se
enfrentan a una elección muy simple son
la rueda de repuesto de macron o son una
fuerza de oposición
el proyecto generó el rechazo de
trabajadores y las movilizaciones en
distintos puntos del país una antesala
de las huelgas que vendrán en los
próximos días
como tal tras el anuncio de la Reforma
del gobierno todos los sindicatos se
reunieron de inmediato para construir
una respuesta común de movilización
interprofesional que se concretará en un
primer día de huelgas y manifestaciones
el 19 de enero de 2023
la batalla no será sencilla para la
propuesta oficialista dado que la
administración de macron no tiene
mayoría en el parlamento una misión tan
difícil como la que tuvo que lidiar
Nicolás sarkozí cuando la propuso en
2010 pero fue abortada por las masivas
protestas de trabajadores